en esta ocasión queremos encontrar el
límite cuando x tiende a menos infinito
de la raíz cuadrada de 4 veces x a la
cuarta menos x
esto a su vez dividido entre 2 x
cuadrada más 3 y como siempre te encargo
que pausa este vídeo y veas si lo puedes
encontrar por tu cuenta bien cuando
intentamos encontrar el límite cuando
extiende a más menos infinito de una
expresión racional justo así es muy útil
pensar en cuál es el término con grado
mayor tanto en el numerador como en el
denominador y luego vamos a dividir el
numerador y el denominador por el
término con grado mayor porque si
hacemos esto vamos a terminar con
algunas constantes y con otras cosas que
se aproximen a 0 mientras x se aproxima
a + menos infinito y así podríamos
encontrar este límite así que hagámoslo
vamos a dividir el numerador por x
cuadrada vamos a multiplicar todo por
uno entre x cuadrada y vamos a hacer lo
mismo para el denominador vamos a
multiplicar por 1
/ x cuadrada y tal vez esté sentado a
decir oye espera aquí tengo una equis
cuarta no es este me terminó con el
exponente mayor pero recuerda este
término está afectado por el radical así
que si lo quieres ver en un nivel más
apto puedes pensar que a esta x cuarta
ya todo lo que está dentro de la raíz
cuadrada le vamos a sacar la raíz
cuadrada así que puedes ver a este
término como un término de segundo grado
y con eso tenemos de nuevo que nuestro
exponente mayor es el exponente de
segundo grado así que vamos a dividir el
numerador y el denominador por equis
cuadrada y si hacemos eso con que nos
vamos a quedar esto va a ser igual
el límite cuando x tiende a menos
infinito y primero hagamos un poco de
álgebra por aquí si tengo déjame ponerlo
con color blanco 1 / x cuadrada que
multiplica a la raíz cuadrada de 4 x
cuarta menos x que es esto que tenemos
en el numerador entonces esto va a ser
igual a bueno a 1 entre la raíz cuadrada
de x cuarta que multiplican a la raíz
cuadrada de 4x cuarta - x que a su vez
es lo mismo que la raíz cuadrada de
bueno de 4 x 4 - x esto a su vez
dividido entre x 4 y esto a su vez es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de quien y
observa que lo único que hice fue
dividir este radical de aquí la raíz
cuadrada de esto entre la raíz cuadrada
de esto y bueno esto va a ser lo mismo
por las propiedades de los exponentes
que tengo 4x cuarta entre x cuarta eso
es igual a 4
- x / x 4a lo cual es igual a 1 / x
cúbica así que el numerador va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 4 menos 1 /
x cúbicas la raíz cuadrada de 4 menos 1
/ x cúbica y ahora pensemos en el
denominador y lo primero que voy a hacer
es dividir 2x cuadrada entre x cuadrada
lo cual me va a dar 2 y después tengo 3
/ x cuadrada muy bien y ahora pasemos a
ver cuál es el límite cuando x tiende a
menos infinito cuando nos aproximamos a
menos infinito
bueno pues observa que esto se
aproximará a 0 1 entre algo que se hace
cada vez más y más y más y más negativo
algo que tiene una magnitud muy grande
bueno pues esto se aproximará a 0 y acá
abajo tengo lo mismo tengo 3 entre algo
que tiene un valor muy muy grande lo
cual me va a dar que todo esto se
aproximará a cero
entonces me va a quedar simplemente la
raíz principal de 4 esto a su vez
dividido entre 2 lo cual es igual a 2
entre 2 lo cual es igual a 1
y ya con esto hemos terminado